herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren über viertel nach acht gegen top
der schlagzeilen machten nächsten 55
minuten wollen wir diskutieren über
themen die uns empören schockieren oder
er vielleicht gar auch freuen und ich
freue mich sehr auf meine gäste heute
abend das ist zum einen unser minister
für verkehr um digitale infrastruktur
andreas scheuer neben dir an meiner
seite die geschäftsführerin des dehoga
verband ist ingrid hartges links von mir
bei ihnen dann rechts wir haben schäfer
politik schiff bei bild und last but not
least journalist hans-ulrich jörges mein
name ist den asik und ich freue mich
sehr dass ich heute ihre gastgeber löste
autorin darf man nicht vergessen das ist
auch ganz wenige in diesem land ich bin
einer davon und ich will direkt
weitergeben so ein verkehrsminister
demnach erhält and thema mitgebracht was
ihn bewegt ja was mich bewegt ist die
lage im deutschen bundestag und die lage
der ampel koalitionäre
gestartet als selbsternannte
fortschritts koalition letzte woche eine
nichts tue koalition in sachen corona
und jetzt eine echte chaos-koalition
wenn ich mir das anschaue dann ist jetzt
schon die ampel mit einem absoluten
blackout morgen wird der gesetzentwurf
der von opel vorgelegt wurde debattiert
im deutschen bundestag er führt nicht
dazu dass wir einen nationalen kraftakt
ihm bekommen zur eindämmung der cholera
pandemie und das bewegt mich massiv
ja aber das wundert mich jetzt ein
bisschen erstens sind sie im
wahlkampfmodus und der wahlkampf ist
vorbei und zweitens hat doch diese
entstehende koalition ihnen gegenüber
nachgegeben es ist doch bei der in der
korona politik einiges
nachgebessert worden was sie wollten was
nun die länder einführen können
beispielsweise kontakt beschränkungen
ausgangssperren letzte was vorher gar
nicht vorgesehen war in dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz
ich frage mich ob wir jetzt nicht einen
stand erreicht haben wo eigentlich das
was die neue opposition wollte und was
die entstehende regierung will sich ganz
gut ausgleichen denn für mich war bei
der frage diese
diese pandemie von nationaler tragweite
zu beenden war für mich gar nicht die
frage der maßnahmen das entscheidende
sondern dass endlich wieder die
parlamente in ihrer rechte kunden also
der bundestag abstimmen muss wenn
schwerwiegende eingriffe in die rechte
vorgenommen werden und die landtage auch
und nun gleichzeitig haben sie die
möglichkeit eine ganze reihe von dingen
zu machen die vorher gar nicht
vorgesehen waren das doch gar nicht
schlecht oder also ich bin nicht im
wahlkampfmodus sondern ich bin im
besorgnis modus gut und wenn ich mir
diesen gesetzentwurf anschauen der
letzte woche durch die fdp absolut weich
leid und alles mögliche was
nicht die pandemie bekämpft dann sehe
ich nur auf die zweite seite das alles
rot das heißt in wenigen tagen in
wenigen stunden wurde eine verschärfung
eines gesetzentwurfes hin gezimmert wo
anhörungen gemacht wurden wo experten
zwei minuten zu wort kommen und das
meine ich mit ihnen und ergiebig völlig
recht die beteiligung des parlaments
wenn wir die beteiligung des parlaments
machen dann macht meine parteienfamilie
cdu/csu einen konstruktiven vorschlag
nämlich die verlängerung der
pandemischen lage um die werkzeuge zu
haben die eingespielt sind aber vor
allem auch die werkzeuge zu haben dass
wir diese pandemie in der jetzigen
situation mit dieser notlage auf den
intensivstationen wirklich bekämpfen und
jetzt ist es stückwerk jetzt dieses
stück minister was bedeutet jetzt
werkzeug die sie zusätzlich hätten wenn
die epidemische lage weiter laufen wird
und die sie jetzt in dem moment nicht
haben gehen sie beispielsweise oder
möchten sie dass beispielsweise
gaststätten restaurants wieder
geschlossen werden können es ist
sozusagen das was die union die
unionsregierten länder möchten meine
volle kommende überzeugung ist dass
beispielsweise die hotellerie die
gastronomie auch der einzelhandel aber
vor allem auch die verkehrsbetriebe mit
hygiene schutzmaßnahmen mit
desinfektionen mit kontrollen beim
eingang vieles vieles in dieser pandemie
aufgebaut haben wir sind ja nicht mehr
im frühjahr 2020 sondern wir haben jetzt
ein eingespieltes thema wie wir
nachvollziehbarkeit machen dennoch ich
will keinen lockdown ich will keinen
lockdown und da müssen wir alle dagegen
kämpfen dass er wiederkommen weil alle
sind genervt und jetzt müssen wir doch
stehen wir haben auf der einen seite die
genervtheit auf der anderen seite sage
ich jetzt mal positiv für die die sich
nicht entscheiden entschieden haben sich
impfen zu lassen
emotionale situationen angst aber wenn
sie keinen locker und wollen dann muss
man sagen es das was die ampel parteien
vorgelegt haben eingang wahres konzept
nein weil es stückwerk ist und dieser
rahmen der erweiterung und verlängerung
der epidemischen lage würde uns in die
rolle versetzen dass wir gemeinsam und
da gebe ich ja jetzt recht der fehler
der
geschäftsführenden bundesregierung oder
der letzten vier jahre oder in der
panini zwei jahre war das
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung in vielen sitzungen mp
chaos die auch morgen wieder stattfinden
alleine entschieden haben und jetzt ist
die verbesserung eingetreten dass sich
die fraktionen die landtage der
bundestag damit wirklich beschäftigen
aber freundlich also fachlich darf ich
nur sagen ein fachlich heißt es mal rein
ist es unbestritten fachlich wenn ich
das sagen darf ist es unbestritten warum
soll ich mir werkzeuge wegnehmen zur
bekämpfung der korona pandemie wenn ich
sie schon beschlossen habe und ersetzen
mit einem stückwerk das dazu führt dass
ein flickenteppich entsteht das
verunsicherung entsteht und das wird
also mit blick auf den ernst der lage
und die großen sorgen unserer betriebe
muss derzeit stornierung hagelt ohne
ende ja nachts weil ich erwarte dass
kein parteiengezänk stattfindet die
bundesregierung die landespolitiker
müssen handlungsfähig sein um diese
pandemie den griff zu bekommen und ich
erwarte dass morgen eine lösung gefunden
wird dazu wir haben bis montag noch ganz
klar den entwurf der ampelkoalition ehre
begrüßt ohne wenn und aber und auch mit
den ergänzungen ja wenn dort jetzt wie
der betriebsschließungen ins auge
gefasst werden muss ganz klar sein unter
welchen engen voraussetzungen dies
überhaupt möglich ist und im zweifel
eben auch die parlamente darüber
entscheiden also da gelten höchste
anforderungen es kann nicht sein dass
wir wieder mit der kreativwirtschaft mit
der veranstaltungswirtschaft in einem
monatelangen lockdown geschickt werden
nein ich möchte dass alle maßnahmen
ergriffen werden wozu impfungen und so
weiter das muss jetzt ans laufen kommen
und dass morgen dazu ein vernünftiger
kompromiss vielleicht erzielt wird wo
man beiden seiten gerecht wird es hat ja
keiner ein interesse daran dass das
gesundheitssystem kollabiert aber ich
musste da so ein bisschen leider also
ihre
prämissen ich glaube ihre hoffnung die
hoffnung möchte ich ein bisschen dämpfen
wenn ich mir anschaue was jetzt von b
länderseite also von seiten der
unionsgeführten bundesländer auch kommt
ist das papier das ist frisch von heute
als beschlussvorlage für die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da sind die
holländer mit dabei das ist so und da
steht nämlich dann drin das muss man
einfach sagen da geht es auch um die
möglichkeit weiterhin beispielsweise
gastronomie schließen zu können und wie
wir ja schon hören auch von länderseite
will die also die unionsgeführten länder
wollen im bundesrat dem dem ampel gesetz
nicht zustimmen das heißt sie werden
erleben dass mutmaßlich samstag sonntag
montag der vermittlungsausschuss dann
tagen muss von bundestag und bundesrat
dann wird genau die frage sein was wird
dann noch in das gesetz der ampel mit
rein verhandelt werden von unionsseite
und dann hören wir zumindest soll da
auch mit drin stehen dass die chance
besteht geschäfte gastronomie hotels
auch möglicherweise wieder schließen zu
können als mich was mich bei dem ganzen
ein relativ optimistisch stimmt zum
einen sind die parlamente wieder im
geschäft und damit können anhörungen im
parlament vorgenommen werden das können
enquete kommissionen eingesetzt wenn es
können experten vorgeladen werden von
allen fraktionen die dann gehört werden
und nicht nur diejenigen die der
kanzlerin genehm sind wie man den
letzten zwei jahren erlebt haben sondern
da kann man querbeet hören und sich dann
können sich die abgeordneten eine
meinung bilden das halte ich für
wahnsinnig wichtig ist auch für die
öffentlichkeit wichtig dass sie nicht
nur einseitig informiert wird zweitens
sie sagen das ist ein flickenteppich das
ist aber ein vorteil wenn die länder
nach ihrer situation
reagieren können sich ein
riesenunterschied zwischen sachsen und
bayern was die infektionen angeht und
schleswig-holstein beispielsweise und
bremen das ist sehr viel einfacher
natürlich muss in süddeutschland stärker
reagiert werden also in norddeutschland
und ich finde es sehr wichtig dass man
dann milian und b länder erklären für
den zuschauer da draußen einer von euch
beiden mein kurs wurde der unterschied
liegt die an du bist doch eigentlich
jeder
das wort aus dem einmal sagen genau die
aaa länder sind die spd geführten länder
und die b länder sind die länder die von
der union man glaubt es gar nicht mehr
nach den letzten jahren dass die länder
die spd-länder seien aber sie sind
wieder in der lage ja da hat man immer
früher dann geht man kann doch nicht
sein das sind doch die band nein nein
nein jetzt ist es in der sache und ich
wollte den satz nur zu ende sagen vor
den armen ländern dass es nicht mehr
bundesweite beschlüsse gibt hinter denen
sich länder dann verschanzen und ständig
nach bundesweiten entscheidung und rufen
die es selber treffen müssen die sollen
die in ihren ländern landeshauptstädten
treffen und dann achten sie auch
politisch dafür ja es müssen sauber das
ist ja mein vorschlag dass ein
kompromiss gefunden wird eine blockade
die hilft jetzt gar keinem weiter also
die lage ist ernst und streitereien der
parteien will auch keiner haben sondern
wir wollen umsetzung haben umsetzung von
von maßnahmen die notwendig sind
flächendeckende impfzentren
beschleunigung des der booster impfung
usw das ist jetzt ganz elementar und
dass alles unternommen wird einen lock
down zu verhindern so und dazu muss man
sagen wenn die diskussion so ist wie sie
jetzt sich darstellt hier will man das
instrument der schließungen haben
seitens der bi länder
und die ampel koalitionäre lehnen das
bislang ab da gibt es vielleicht ein
kompromiss der gestalt dass man sagt
unter welchen engen engen voraus so
regionale lockt das überhaupt nur
möglich sehr geschadet sie das den mut
haben und die schule durch thema eine
gewisse sendezeit was wäre denn ihre
lösung also sie greifen das an was
würden sie denn machen also ich sehe
keinen widerspruch und dazwischen das
was frau hat gesagt und unserem
vorschlag konstruktiv die bestehende
lage zu verlängern die epidemische lage
zu verlängern an dieser stelle weil nach
meiner wahrnehmung es schon eingespielt
ist und vor allem mit diesem rahmen
möglichkeiten entstehen dieses papier
ist entstanden aus einem aus einer
vorbereitung aus dem kanzleramt mit aaa
länder und b länder also spd geführt und
unionsgeführte länder das ist nicht ein
vorschlag alleine der unionsgeführten
länder und das war es herr jörges
gesorgt hat beteiligung des parlaments
was ich in den letzten tagen erlebt habe
ist eine basta-politik aller ampel wenn
wissenschaftler also jetzt sage ich mir
nur ein beispiel wir machen seit früher
2020 klare begleitung des öffentlichen
verkehrs mein bereich und stellen fest
abgestimmt mit dem robert-koch-institut
niedriges infektionsrisiko das ist
ähnlich wie bei restaurants und hotels
aber ich bleibe zumal meinem fachbereich
und wir begleiten das die ganze zeit
wissenschaftlich osten sagt in dieser
anhörung stattgefunden in dieser woche
also der öffentlichen verkehrsbereich
sieht er nicht als infektionsherd wir
strengen uns an wir schauen die
flugzeugkabinen an wir begleiten
wissenschaftlich und die apple geht her
und sagt jetzt sofort 3g im öffentlichen
verkehr so meine vertreter des
ministeriums sind in der anhörung haben
die rechtlichen bedenken die
organisatorischen bedenken und auch die
wissenschaftlich fachlichen bedenken zu
zu gehör gebracht und dann wurde von der
ampel einfach gesagt das spielt jetzt
keine rolle es geht nicht mehr ums ob
wir machen das ja aber wenn sie gerade
hat basta politik aller opel und des 26
union und spd steht 3g beispielsweise in
der bahn und im öffentlichen nahverkehr
in das heißt auch die unionsgeführten
länder finden das gut für sich
doch ich habe einen moment
ich habe gerade eine sonder
verkehrsministerkonferenz erlebt mit den
vertretern der länder die gesagt haben
originalton von vertretern der ampel
parteien in den ländern das ist und das
sind wir uns fachlich einig zitat
quatsch steht hier drin dann ist alles
quatsch was drinsteht nicht meine worte
an der stelle ich finds auch so ich bin
ein
verkehrsmittel angesprochen ich sage nur
dass minister von grünen und fdp gerade
vor ein paar minuten in der sonder
verkehrsministerkonferenz in der
beratung zum besten gegeben habe